the Joe Rogan experience you know I've
been talking to Norm Macdonald a lot
lately we're gonna I think we're gonna
start the podcast up again so thank God
for that and get tested yeah bring him
in here and get tested too yeah you know
what yeah we're gonna have I think we
would kill for you to be the first guest
all right good god yeah we have some
good guests lined up so now we just were
just gonna figure it out yeah so you're
all set to get tested today - Oh perfect
I know you don't have it cuz you haven't
gone anywhere but you yeah exactly I hid
an app a bunch of people and give them
acid I think that's been done terrible
[ __ ] when you're gonna do your thing
with norm again yes we we've been
planning for a while now so now we're
just going to we just need to put all
the the nuts and bolts into place and
then get a get a studio get a camera and
just do it but you're gonna be the first
guess I'm in alright good so tell me
when so I can I could plan ahead we're
shooting the first one in the fall so no
okay so you know are you gonna plan it
out you're gonna map it out in advance
nice
I can't wait and there's still yeah you
know I mean I'd listen I love norm to
pieces he's my all-time favorite human
beings the same man that have ever lived
I have a great story about norm me and
him on a plane and randomly this is
crazy but true randomly twice I sat next
to him on planes just random oh wow yeah
totally randomly like what's up norm
what's up norm like crazy this is
happening again and both times it was a
blast but one time we're flying back and
he's like yeah I used to smoke I had to
give it up it's [ __ ] terrible for you
but I sometimes I miss it but glad I
quit I'm like aha well you know how long
he's hip in he's telling me all these
months you stopped smoking this net
we're talking soon as he land he walks
right into the [ __ ] store buys a
carton of cigarettes and he's opening a
cigarette he's lighting it before he
gets out the door and I go what do you
do do all that talk about smoke and I
had to have one and the flight from heat
from I forget were even were two times
both times are just like the best
flights like just like having a
audience of one next to one of the
greatest comics ever talk [ __ ] yeah he's
probably you know he's probably like in
my top three favorite stand-up comics of
all time and he's a real guy he's a
great great guy the two greatest people
in my life in comedy have been Norman
Spade they've just been so good to me
and I love them both and they're both
equally hilarious in different ways but
norm I'll never forget how quick he was
and good he was at hosting that podcast
we had Larry King on one time and Larry
was like norm I don't think they're
gonna give you a show you know the way
because he was just [ __ ] outlandish
saying the most crazy [ __ ] Larry King
and there's like you know what no I'm
he's like 50 is in the radio business
the one thing I learned is I never I
rarely talk I always listened that's why
I always learned from the guests because
I'm always listening in Norris can I
interrupt you there I can't wait to come
back with this podcast norm is the
hidden king of the internet if he
decided to have a podcast it would be
the biggest podcast of all time if you
just a regular basis I know we just need
to get motivated
he's buck wild dude yes and he's always
been always he's there's whatever the
filter it doesn't even screw in his head
like there's not there's no filter there
was never a place for it Charles Manson
a comedy now he loves Manson does it
really we're gonna will definitely get
O'Neill no way yeah he's a Manson fiend
huge how much does he know about the
case I think he knows I'm sure he's read
the books he's read that book that Kaos
book okay yeah good I need to talk to
him about it yeah yeah
[Applause]